[Musique]
quand on parle de réinstallation des
familles et nous et dans le grand nord
dans les années 50
en fait on parle du gouvernement
canadien qui a réinstallé une dizaine de
familles de village qui s'appelait à
l'époque paritarisme qui s'appelle
maintenant inukjuak ses 10 à milan était
embarqué sur un navire que c'était le
cigare et qui ont été amenés dans deux
endroits en extrême arctique donc à
grise fjord et à resolute bay ce projet
là de dire on va prendre des inuit puis
on va les envoyer dans leur retour à la
vie traditionnelle
on va voir comment ça va fonctionner ça
a été un petit peu un projet
expérimental
ces familles se sont fait déposer sur
une plage ou mode où il a commencé à
neiger
on n'avait pas de bateau de charlot pour
aller pêcher il connaissait pas le
territoire ils sont arrivés dans des
endroits désolé des endroits aride des
endroits où il faisait plus froid que
vous habitez où il faisait noir trois
mois par année où le gouvernement aussi
à mal gérer l'approvisionnement qui
devait leur fournir pour leur
réinstallation la ba devait y avoir 6
ans peau de caribou pour les aider à se
vêtir devait avoir des détentes
il devait avoir plein de choses qui 60%
à peu près de ce matériel n'est jamais
arrivé finalement au lieu de six en
poudre caribou ils en ont eu 60
ils ont manqué mourir de froid
l'apprendre le premier hiver est aussi
faut pas oublier qu'à cette époque dans
les années 50 le territoire d île de
l'arctique était un petit peu fragile
des états unis leur lui qui est un petit
peu de loin c'était la guerre froide et
le canada n'avait pas de citoyens qui
habitait sur le territoire
[Musique]
le ministre john key est allé à une joie
qu et faire ses excuses pour ces fausses
promesses ça a été quelque chose de très
très touchant les inuit l'attendait ses
excuses depuis très longtemps
[Musique]
je